hey guys so today I got a chance to dive
into the arena that you're going to be
able to access on October 25th and it is
fun it's a lot of fun
it's accessed at the filing shrine'
bonfire and there are three types of
undead matches that you're able to queue
for so the first one is a dual style of
combat where you're pitted against one
opponent and the first one to kill the
opponent wins and then the match ends no
Estes in this game mode but there's a
similar one called the two-player brawl
which is like the duel I just described
except the game doesn't end when you
kill your opponent it ends after 300
seconds and the one with the most kills
wins there is Estes in this game mode
and then there's two versus two and
three versus three team combat where you
and your teammates have to try and get
more kills than the enemy team and
there's also four player and six player
brawls which is every man for himself
basically the player with the most
killing blows at the end of it all wins
so in addition to these cues so we've
got one versus one we've got team fights
and we've got brawls there was the
option to queue into team fights in
general or brawls in general which I
assume allows you to get into whichever
queue is faster as long as you don't
mind how many players you're playing
with but for some reason I'm not allowed
to show you the actual menu screen so
there's probably some more work that
needs to be done on it for example we
were only able to play one map but there
was the option to choose other maps so
there might be some more work going into
the game modes we'll have to wait and
see anyway so right now on the screen
you are seeing the four player brawl and
this was hectic as you can see I can't
imagine what the six player brawl will
look like at all times
you're either anxious that someone's
going to come behind you and backstab
you or you're anxious that someone's
going to steal your kill because all
that matters is how many killing blows
you land so it might be a good strategy
to have like a secondary weapon that's
really good at chasing people down and
securing a kill something like that
but this was a lot of fun the team
fights are a bit more honorable these
were the ones I enjoyed the most there
were a lot of cool moments where like
the fight would split off into 1v1
and then you might kill your opponent
and then you go and gank the other guy
who remains while he waits for his
teammate to respawn and just in general
there's a cool dynamic that comes from
playing with a teammate
so yeah in everything except duels you
start off with one of each Estus flask
which replenishes if you get a kill and
sometimes when I got a kill my health
was restored to full I haven't quite
figured out what the trigger for that
was though but this system felt pretty
fair while I was playing respawning
players give off a big wrath of the gods
style explosion which helps with their
positioning a little bit and all in all
I think this is something that Dark
Souls 3 is PvP needed for longevity
team-based dueling adds so much depth to
fights in general and now you don't have
to worry so much about Estus chugging
which makes it much more interesting and
now you have somewhere to go for fast
consistent duels and it's ante Estes
it's anti gank squad and I think that's
good for the game but they are playing
it pretty safe while this expanded the
PvP it's a lot like the arena's from
Dark Souls 1 and there's not much reward
as far as I can tell other than just the
gameplay itself you know you're playing
for the fun of playing which is fine but
I think it would have been a bit bolder
if they introduced a ranking system
perhaps which might be announced on
release we'll see but I at least feel
like there should be some incentive
maybe covenant rewards for winning a
match you take on the phantom color of
your covenant after all so I think that
would make sense but unfortunately also
it doesn't seem easy to queue with a
friend which I find kind of
disappointing because there are a lot of
people me included who would like to
play team-based combat with a mate there
is password matching but as it stands
I've heard that you have to fill the
entire room with people all using that
same pass
which only really makes this a feature
if you have a group of friends that want
to play against each other or for a
streamer or a community like ours for
example that wants to organize a Fight
Club based on a set of rules or just
play within the community and that is
pretty cool
if I do another PvP video I might give
you guys a password and we'll all queue
up together under it we could even use
certain rules like whip only or things
like that and speaking of weapons the
two new weapons I tested were the Onyx
great sword and this Valor Hart paired
weapon so the Onyx great sword is very
standard l2 and wreathes it in flame and
the moveset is nothing new but valor
Hart this Gladius and this small shield
this is fantastic it's actually a paired
weapon which a few clever detectives and
the last video had already kind of
puzzled out and it hasn't also moveset
the most notable thing is this running
art to attack in my opinion because it
does this awesome lunge stab that
actually I believe activates the shield
during the jump so you can't get hit
during it properly and there's this
weapon art shield bash attack which is
fantastic at breaking guards it's a
great all-rounder weapon and there where
are the weapons I could test I believe
there's a javelin that you might see
another PvP footage so I'll put some
other PvP streamers and youtubers in the
description so you can check out their
videos if they make one and unless I'm
missing something in my footage poise
wasn't fixed but it's going to be check
out the description for the patch notes
that are dropping soon flashes of Ariane
del because in the patch notes it's
listed that there are a ton of balance
changes and they actually seem like
they're going to be very significant so
the most notable one is that poise is
going to become and I quote more
valuable for heavy weapons and armor and
additionally they're actually saying
that they're going to improve weapon
arts in their entirety animations as
well as performance so that's way more
than just tweaking a few numbers if the
animations are changing for some weapon
arts this could be a pretty significant
overhaul
but other than that you probably don't
want to see too much mediocre PvP
gameplay so I'll just let it run for a
bit and there will be more to say on
this when it comes out and we see that
balance patch so they played it safe but
this was a lot of fun I wish I had a mic
going while I was recording this because
I was invited to the Namco office and
they roped a few employees into playing
with us and we'll had so much fun I
think we made so much noise that anyone
else working in that office probably
didn't get too much work done it was
great
apologies for lack of uploads lately I
ran into a dead end with two videos and
I had to scrap them for the most part
although I will salvage them at some
point and you will be seeing a prepare
to cry if all goes well before the DLC
drops soon it's all written and ready
and as soon as the 25th hits I will be
ready to go have on the uploads thank
you for watching I hope this is
interesting to some people I just want
to get it out there and I'll see you
guys in the next one
you